you
hi everyone is cheering let's have a
look at another game between alpha zero
playing on the wide end and stockfish we
have another Queen's Indian defense
LightSquared Bishop skom p-ting for the
long diagonal Bishop b4 check Bishop d2
and in the previous game I reviewed
between these two the bishop drops back
to e7 not here dark square bishop Tsar
exchanged Queen recapturing it's the
queen Knight who wants to post up on c3
this is a strong square d5 both sides
Castle C takes d5 e takes d5 Knight c3
Knight B to d7 and b4 I like this move B
form these guys here will help to combat
blacks Queen side structure this guys
fighting for c5 and also b2 is now
vacated for the Queen she's surprisingly
enough functions very well even if just
for a short time from the B to post
x-raying the unprotected bishop it may
be more importantly helping to
facilitate an always desirable move like
Knight to e5 whenever you have this King
side fianchetto a knight to f3 arcs to
me a knight on f3 you want to at some
point play your Knight to e5 and say my
knight has been improved and my bishop
can see the world a queen from v2 helps
out with this move continuing we have c6
Queen to be - a5 is met with b5 the 5 is
essentially saying no I'm not going to
help your rook out I'm not going to
allow your a pawn to make it capture c5
is the follow-up
and from here white I guess is kind of
treating this
as if it's just a true hanging pawn
structure just as if it's c5 and d5
those pawns just by themselves you know
c5 d5 without the b6 and d4 upon it at
any point it could change into exactly
that after D takes e5 B takes e5 so in
other words the white rooks are going to
post up on the C and D files
rook c1 queen e79 a four places are
constraint on this guy he now has a job
which should be a
after d1 analyst moves 16
changes the structure with c4 and we
pretty much play within this structure
on the queenside for who great majority
of the game for sure it'll change a
little bit on the kingside but if c4
isn't played here I just want to touch
on how play might develop these are
these are important things to assess how
might play continued for just a few
moves
if c4 isn't played here suppose
something natural like getting this guy
involved half open file this is how play
might develop it can open up a great
deal and white is the side who would
stand better currently down upon but the
pond will be won back and every white
piece is fantastic white also has a
flight square black needs to invest some
time for that this would be desirable
for white so
takes this opportunity to shut things
down c4 acquire a protected past pun
this is a very valuable pun but this
Queen night would be the one who is
responsible for making sure he doesn't
go any further and it's the Queen night
who will exert a great amount of
pressure on the black center from c3
continuing Knight to e5 and f4 so really
super gluing this night in to e5 rook F
to d8
it's just centralizing a little bit the
Queen has done her job supporting a
Knight to e5 move there's nothing
happening on the B file anymore so play
is now turning towards the King side of
the board here with all these pawns
basically being fixed at this stage
rook f1 Queen to d6 a4 again nothing
going on here this is a kingside game
there's some space that black has with
the c4 pawn but he's under canoe there's
some space he's past but he's under
control white also has space with b5
there's no action going on on the Queen
side so who is better on the Kings side
it's white who slowly grabs a little bit
of space rook c8 III and now in comes g4
little by little the black pieces are
finding themselves rocked back f5 has
been with f6 Knight f3 and let's just
pause for a moment we're 26 moves in
this is a hundred move game there's a
lot of maneuvering that comes about from
this stage who stands better and why
again the queenside ish is shut down if
we have a look at this the key 16
squares here what do you notice about to
these 16 squares you would like to have
both nights somewhere in these 16
squares white already has that look at
the black nights
soon one of them will be able to occupy
an okay square good square on Dee's foot
on d6 but aside from that square one of
the nights is always going to be a bit
clumsy the e7 night in particular is not
a very well placed piste and nor is the
Bishop on b7 the knight on c3 exerts
pressure on d5 so will the bishop and
not long enough the knight on f3 will do
one better by improving one rank getting
out of the bishops way and they'll be
yet another piece putting pressure on d5
continuing Queen 87 so what can we say
White has a much more superior pawn
structure in this middle game position
Queen d7 follows Queen f2 a little
repositioning fighting for efore and
some pressure on d5 so these guys are
always gonna have to stick around
watching over that point rook to f8
Queen g3 eventually we're going to have
the Queen's exchanged in this one not
too much is changing with the structure
Queen a3 this is I don't even know how
to describe this just some kind of silly
active hoof I don't know how to describe
this there's no there's no issue with
the Queen here she's not coordinated
with any other black piece white on the
other hand has perfect coordination
Brooks defending each other
Knights defended a pawns defended
everything is strung together for white
so following up we have h5 Queen c7
throwing a couple punches and from here
we have Queen d6 in the Queen's get
exchanged if you're wondering why is
queen takes bishop not played in this
position it's because we would have this
pretty weird variation where the Queen
could actually be given up and we obtain
a roughly equal position with Queen
takes pawn takes and yeah don't exist
don't ask me how exactly to assess this
position it's pretty crazy
evaluation at depth 23 is saying that
it's equal
apparently alpha zero sees better in
simply exchanging Queens here
and continuing with now night g3
preparing to win this pawn and one more
change of the structure here so this is
an important moment move 37 I touched on
this this moment here with c4 you know
if c4 isn't played and instead rook here
how am i play developed well in this
game we have h4 played why is maybe this
capture not played the best explanation
I could give for this is that the H file
is now opened and white will be able to
make better use of the H file than black
in fact it's not long off before you
would see something like the knight
posting up on f4 3 minor pieces would
then be striking at d5 which would
require the support of at least one of
the black rooks that would be an
inconvenience for black and white could
then double up on the H file and
probably do something there black sees
it best to keep things a bit closed with
h4
9 h5 follows night g5
this is blacks best piece here so
putting a constraint on one of the white
pieces observing a big gap in whites
position this is one of the weakest
squares in whites camp okay so to is d3
that's a square that's difficult to
reach for black but certainly efore the
night the rook the pawn are all
converging there the bishop has some
influences well Ani form
so some more maneuvering and what more
to add here Bishop h1 move 42 is
actually throwing a punch you see the
threat here vacating g2 for what reason
the threat here is to simply scoop up
the pawn in two moves now stockfish
allows this and we're just a couple
moves away and alpha zero is going to be
up upon so this definitely caught my
attention and I wondered why not try to
save this pawn
in the in the game we had rook d6
and simply night g2 and night takes h4
follows so can black do something
different so this is one of the last
points in this 100 move game that I
really want to touch on cuz from there
once alpha zeroes up upon its and no it
just seems like a to simple conversion
for alpha zero we now if a zeroes up
upon so the thing I'd like to question
here is what would happen if the rip
played to h8 preparing to me Knight g2
with King to g8
a good way forward for white in this
position would be to exchange would be
to get rid of blacks best piece this guy
here on g5 and who's going to do that
the Queen night that's going to be the
one that this is the piece that's going
to remove blacks best defender nigh b12
d2 to f3 let me play some moves out we'd
play out something like this I believe
that this would be a good plan not night
to have three just yet instead Knight h5
so now the rook is cut off and let's get
one more move in there let's say rook to
e8 since their I can't defend this point
anymore Knight f3 Knight takes bishop
takes and you could see now that soon
we're going to have a knight on f4
exerting pressure on d5 the bishop is
there you do a knight comparison knight
on f4 versus a knight on e7 and without
the knight on d5 there's now even in a
nice pawn break at some stage y can go
forward with and then in the form of g5
opening up h5 for the bishop this is
this is a way forward for white if black
tries to hang on to the H pawn in the
game it's rook to d6 and white and just
a couple moves simply picks up the H fun
pawn takes pawn G takes if the knight
captures well black would be helped out
this Knight is a dead piece and the rook
would then be brought to life so pawn
takes pawn and let's just see how white
converts from here rip - G - this Knight
is enormous he didn't have to make a lot
of moves and he had that idea in case
black tried to hang on to the pawn it
was the Queen Knight who would be there
to kind of crack the position open
so King f6 he also has another maneuver
still in him
Bishop f3 just improving little by
little a bishop from e2 functions very
well at some stage there can be an e4
pawn break and maybe a timely Bishop
takes pawn move who knows maybe if the
King is on a light square that that move
would hit with check then so it's also
getting out of the rooks way continuing
Bishop g4 9 c8 Bishop f3 and another
pawn break h4 and the white pieces
simply come to life from here if pawn
takes pawn this rook is getting way too
active with rook to g6 so black tries a
pin white simply pushes so now there's
two passers four passed pawns total but
the black pawns are really posing no
danger to team white and this King if
he's ever dislodged this guy is gonna
run really fast row t8 Bishop g2 97 h6
trick h8 rook h3 rook h7 and King G 1 1
little prep move the King is getting a
little bit closer towards the center
maybe in some cases this pawn would like
to be defended by the King and the final
maneuver here Knight to d1 preparing
Knight F 2 into G 4 that would be a
killer dislodging the King and then
there's another pond that's ready to
step foot on the sixth rank so G 4 is
played rook h5 this pawn could never be
successfully captured there's always
some way to capitalize on the pin efore
night to e3 currently it doesn't even
have enough attackers on it but the ping
could always be exploited if it's ever
captured g3 follows so can't make use of
f2 so the night is just going to return
to c3 and then simply scoop up the g3
pump he's way too overextended at this
stage 92 the H pawn is exchanged G pawn
is picked up white remains a pawn ahead
and from here just improved the Kings
nights are now gone he did his job and
this guy here is a big issue in this end
game simply unproductive that's a bad
Bishop whose
what can he do he has one Square to go
to
no good rook h1 follows and from here
it's just a mopping up of the pawns
Iike go nowhere white controls this
square and if he gets if he tries to get
too active of course he can't go here
but if he tries to get active this rook
can always go to a7 and keep pressure on
the bishop and the rook always has to
have the responsibility to defend the
bishop so let's just see the conversion
from here another 25 moves before
resignation we've seen this happen
before the picot just gets to a point in
the end game where the pawns just fall
one by one and there's just not much
that you can do playing against one of
the a really bad piece in this game the
light-square bishop and not too much
longer we're gonna have resignation in
this one coming up right at move 100
after a6 it's at this point that
stockfish throws in the towel if the
game you did continue playing it out
straight to checkmate this is just one
of the many ways that it could have
finished rook being captured King Creek
being over and the D pawn running up a
little bit with a pretty neat matin to
finish it off so what more to say with
this game
my middle gate structure was simply
superior and your bad bishop was very
bad again
you